and as you can see we are joined once
again on the program by the education
secretary Jillian Keegan lovely to see
you this morning Minister
um if I want to start not on your brief
if at all possible just before the
weather there we were examining the
events that took place at the Grand
National and of course I understand you
have Goodwood in your constituency over
the flats I just wonder if you have a
view on what we are seeing at horse
racing events like that we've heard from
the rspca uh in the past 24 hours at
saying that horse racing should conduct
an urgent review so that we never again
exit a festival of racing with three
dead horses what's your review on the
matter well to be honest I I'm not all
over the top of it but I am from
Liverpool as well so the Grand National
I know is extremely uh precious and
obviously everybody puts there and it's
it you know it often has
um attract attention Etc but I'm sure
that the bodies will will work together
you know the thing the great thing about
this country is you know when things
happen when when tragic things happen
and particularly to animals and horses
you know all the people the relevant
people do look to see what what can be
done and and what changes need to be
made and that's happened a couple of
times actually after the Grand National
well we are speaking to the Jockey Club
a little later in the program so we'll
pick that up with them but but let's
talk strikes and we will start on on the
NHS certainly looks likely that we are
going to see a period of industrial
unrest from nurses potentially going all
the way to to Christmas are the
government entirely sanguine with the
fact that you know the offer on the
table is the final offer and that there
will be no more negotiations well that
offer has been accepted actually by all
of the unions the agenda for change
unions which is actually different from
the teachers unions but the agenda for
change unions all accepted that offer
um it is worth uh I think around about 5
000 pounds uh over the period that they
were negotiating it for to the average
nurse
um and of course it's been put to I
think two of the unions now one of
them's accepted it one of them very
narrowly rejected it despite
um the general secretary actually
recommending it think what happens now
is there's two unions that are ballot in
there those two unions obviously we need
to wait for the ballot there is a a
meeting an agenda for change an HS
council meeting staff council meeting
which I think is the second of May and
from that we'll then get
um you know the results formally from
all of the ballots but we are
approaching a point if we haven't
reached already aren't we we're patient
safety is going to become an issue I I
again just asked the question is it not
worth at least maintaining that dialogue
with the nurses unions in any kind of
attempt is to stop that potential harm
taking place well of course we always
keep dialogues open
um and we will also be going forward
um in the case of teaching with the
independent peer review process now but
the reality is what we're trying to do
is get a fair and reasonable balance
between the taxpayers we're also trying
to make sure we have inflation don't
make it worse we know inflation has been
the cause of this we know it's been a
spike it's everybody's suffered from it
not even just in our country and we know
that what the government needs to do is
to get inflation down so so that we
don't have this problem for everybody
and we can't
um you know and we've also obviously put
energy relief schemes in place because
we know how how tough this has been for
people that's why we put those in place
but what you can't have and patient
safety but also the backlog I mean you
know I was talking to people yesterday
one who just luckily had an operation
one who'd had theirs canceled on a visit
I did in my constituency and it's you
know it's it's really tough for people
already they've had a delay through the
pandemic in many cases a lot of people
in pain and we rely on our NHS and we
rely on our staff being there and we
rely on our education system again let's
talk about the teachers I mean they
quite clearly are not happy with what's
on the table in part because of the way
it's funded offering them four and a
half percent but most of that money has
to come out of existing budgets doesn't
it well what happened so I got the this
role on the 25th of October and the
independent pay review body had already
recommended a 5.4 increase which was
higher than the three percent that the
department had budgeted for and actually
the schools are budgeted for as well so
there was three percent in the budget so
the first thing I had to do there was a
letter saying we need two billion pounds
more to pay for this increase plus the
other inflationary pressures so that
money we got in the Autumn statement and
that was to take it up to 5.4 and then
what we've done is we've looked at that
and said if we offer well if this had
been accepted the extra thousand pounds
and the four and a half percent looking
at those School budgets we would have to
put an extra 620 million to that yeah so
we have we've calculated it the ifs have
also looked at it and said yes there is
enough money going into school budgets
to cover those costs but it is
lecturing us all on the fact that math
isn't important but even I understand
that if you offer a four and a half
percent pay rise but only funds not
point five percent of that that's an
awful lot of money that has to come from
because within the budget there was an
assumption so this is very good for the
maths you're right maths to 18 because
sometimes you make assumptions and
sometimes you have to look so an
assumption was made that there would be
a 3.5 rise affordability within that and
there was assumptions made about energy
costs the energy costs have come down
since that point so if it's recalculated
now we calculate and the ifs agree that
the assumption is that that four percent
is included in that extra money already
and half a percent is extra now by the
way
but I think this is really important
because this is the key thing for
teachers I think 89 of the teachers said
they'd reject the deal and that went
down to 31 in a survey if they thought
it was funded so what we what we're
doing now is making sure that we get
more independent verification of our
position and the ifs that it is fully
funded just just on the the speech that
the prime minister is making later today
about the anti-mass mindset I understand
that for a number of people in this
government Matt is a big priority take
what Liz trust you know the former prime
minister herself said she said you know
it is no exaggeration to say this is a
make or break period in the history of
mass in this country we are now playing
catch-up the support has not been there
for Mass teachers in this country not
the Iron Will and determination to
encourage more young people to take the
subject after gcses I mean the problem
with that statement is as you see on the
screen there let's just said that when
she was education Minister back in 2012.
if there was problem if there are
problems with maths provision in this
country surely it is the fault of the
government that has been in and you know
it's more than the fingers and two of my
hands but I think roughly 13 years so
2012 was when she said that and she was
correct in 2012. we completely
revolutionized how we teach maths in
this country in 2015. so what we did is
we did a lot of um research and we
worked with lots of people
um to look at um you know how the best
maths teaching in the world and who was
best at maths in the world and we
basically took the single career method
and we adapted it here
in 2012. and we introduced introducing
we have an anti-mass mindset yeah
there's only one group of people we can
blame so so if you want to listen to
what we've done because I think it's
really important so we've introduced
Mastery into all of our primary schools
and now into secondary schools and we
have 40 expert maths hubs helping people
be able to teach them we also have 12 we
can't recruitment we also have three
what's called MP cues to enable existing
teachers at primary level to get more
comfortable teaching maths so that's
been a very important as well we've also
put bursaries in place to get more maths
teachers that's quite recent and if you
look at the the results of the younger
children they are doing really well now
in maths and what we've done is got a
completely new way of teaching math
different from when you and I taught it
what we're saying is if we take that all
the way through we've also reformed
gcses and a levels a levels sit there
since then since Liz trust said that is
now the number one a-level choice is
maths so there's been huge amounts of
progress but now we want to go further
and we are an outlier we're the only
country in the oecd pretty much that
doesn't do maths to 18 and maths is such
an important part in a digital world
that our young people this next
generation are going to be competing in
and looking for jobs soon at Minister
you'll be entirely pleased to hear that
we are out of time so I won't be able to
run through the list of math questions
that I of course answered the one thing
I could work out was that the
probability of you asking me a math
question was a hundred percent there we
go thought that was the case Minister
could type in the program this morning